before we go any further i do have to
let you all know that my channel is
sponsored by keeps which means we'll
hear more from them in the middle of the
video
hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are doing
another q a
this time for july a friendly reminder
that if you want to ask questions for
the next video you can do so by leaving
the questions in the comments
of this video but let's get to the
questions shall we i think i'm probably
gonna make this one the headline just
because i saw
a fair amount of confusion regarding
this which i feel like i've been very
clear
but you know you can't expect everyone
to see everything um
so the question is and there are a few
of them and have been a few of them
scattered across a number of videos
anyway
this one is from marcus yes and it says
why did you move back to australia is it
true that you are pregnant
i didn't move back to australia i am
currently
in australia but i didn't move back to
australia i just came home to visit my
family because my
sister was pregnant she has had her baby
um
my niece and also my god daughter which
is very exciting
and it probably appears like i moved
back because this wasn't just
kind of a regular holiday because of
covert restrictions in australia
i have to do a two-week mandatory hotel
quarantine
where the police basically pick you up
from the airport and whisk you off to a
hotel
um the minute that i landed and i
usually only come home for two weeks so
spending two weeks in a hotel meant that
i was automatically going to spend
a full month in australia to have at
least two weeks out of the hotel but
then i also knew and you know
told my employers and loved ones that
leaving australia would be
difficult and that the date could shift
um
so basically i've just been in australia
for a longer amount of time than i
normally
would and it's been absolutely wonderful
but no i am definitely not pregnant my
sister was
no longer is i have had questions like
where's all your batman stuff how are
you moving all your collectibles
um yeah i'm not moving back to australia
sorry that i seem to have caused a fair
amount of confusion there i have seen a
number of comments along these lines
i'm just home visiting family and it's
been
absolutely lovely on that note a lot of
people been like how have you taken as
much time off work
uh i didn't have a single day off not
the whole time that i was home i was
just working on american time
which did mean a lot of 3 a.m start
times sometimes 5 a.m start times if i
was a little bit luckier
so i was still working for santa monica
studio the entire time that i was home
so that didn't uh stop for even a second
okay next up bad soda production sir not
saying you should one way or another but
have you considered naturalizing as an
american or does that not appeal to you
uh they don't want me to so if you're in
the us
on a work visa they don't want you to be
becoming a citizen
and it is i think even part of the terms
of my visa that i will not
try to become a citizen um
it also doesn't appeal to me truthfully
and is extremely complicated and
expensive so
a whole lot of reasons not to there
including the country not wanting me to
bradley fiore said hi alana what are
your thoughts on starfield's exclusivity
it was fairly reasonable to think the
game would be on playstation when it was
announced but after three years of
anticipation
playstation players are just now
learning that they cannot play it
without a pc or an xbox
feels like they are taking something
away from playstation players more than
they are giving something extra xbox
players if the game and its exclusivity
were announced together i'd be
disappointed that i couldn't play it but
i wouldn't be bothered by it you seem to
often have an interesting and unique
take on things like this so i'm
wondering if you could help me
rationalize it
um i think for a game
that you've only just seen a tiny
trailer of
the idea that you're losing something
when you still kind of don't really know
that well what it is or how it's going
to play
doesn't really make sense you don't even
know what this game's going to be and
you feel like it's being taken away from
you
i don't feel like that's fair no i think
that it makes perfect sense
um that you know the owner of the studio
who is making the game would want it to
be exclusive to their platform i don't
feel like players have been misled
i would agree if they said it was going
to be on playstation and on xbox
i think the conversation where the
existing franchises like fallout
and elder scrolls are concerned is a
little bit more complicated
because people on those platforms have
been die-hard fans of both those
platforms and those franchises for such
a long time that i do think
that that is probably a more complicated
decision for them to make but starfield
if you were assuming it was on
playstation even though nobody said that
at any point i feel like that's kind of
on you but i know that people get very
spicy over this kind of thing
and anything that pertains to console
wars so i'm sorry for whoever i've upset
uh because i know you're there i know
you're upset in my comment section right
now
because i said everything i just said
i'm sorry
hi zack d destroyer sad i'm curious to
know with your years of experience in
writing and now being
that a professional role of yours it's
been a professional role of mine for
nine years
seriously my job at ign was a writer i
started out in magazines
i did plenty of writing at funhouse and
rooster teeth
i've been a professional writer for a
long time anyway sorry
how do you deal with writer's block do
you have any advice for newbie writers
um i've not dealt with a tremendous
amount of writer's block i
especially professionally i'm generally
just totally
capable of getting things done to a
deadline because i have to otherwise
i'll let people down and i'll let the
team down
it can be a little bit harder for me
with personal projects to get things
finished
because there are so many other things
that i feel like i could be working on
at all times
but my number one piece of advice or the
thing that helped me most for actually
finishing something that you're trying
to write whether it be a screenplay or a
story or whatever
is to at first write it like it's a
kid's book write it
very very simply um just to make sure
it's done
focus on complexity and editing and
fleshing things out later
but first just get this stuff on the
paper even if that's bullet points in
some places
steven goodman said possible question
for july what was the first game you
remember where the sun came up
the following morning and you were still
playing mine was syndicate on pc back in
1993 and i had worked the following day
i was born in 1993 good year i would
think
pretty much anything on the nintendo 64
um that came out you know at that though
i had played pc games
i played a lot of age of empires as a
kid um i
and doom i had played pc games before
the n64 came out it came out at the
right time
for me to get very very into things that
might be a little bit more complicated
if i were to guess i would probably say
it was banjo-tooie i was obsessed
but i also loved perfect dark i'm sure i
would have done perfect dark with my
sister
uh goldeneye jet force gemini ocarina of
time majora's mask
all the classics i would think the
nintendo 64 as an entire console
probably kept me up until the sun came
up a number of times
it is time to talk about keeps
for anyone who doesn't know keeps is a
subscription service that focuses on
making it easier and more affordable for
men to treat
male pattern baldness online i always
want to say before i get into this but i
take keeps on as a sponsor because i do
think that men should have options for
things that they feel insecure about but
i always want to say that i'm not saying
you should feel insecure if you're bold
just letting you know an option that
exists and i do have friends who have
tried
keeps who have had great experiences but
if you didn't already know two out of
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35.
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair
left with keeps a licensed doctor will
review your information
online and recommend the right hair loss
treatment plan for you then your
treatment is shipped directly to your
door every three months
you can message your keeps doctor 24 7
with any questions or concerns you may
have along the way and track your
progress with keeps's progress tracking
tool keeps offers generic versions of
the fda approved medications for hair
loss which makes it more affordable
as well find out why keeps has more five
star reviews than any of its competitors
and why hundreds and thousands of men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention
so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
alanapierce or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash alana pierce back to the
video
nicholas santos said question for the
next q a are you worried about the
facebook data stuff with the oculus
quest 2 i really wanted that headset but
if
it's as awfully intrusive as i heard i
don't know if i will index and htc vive
are too expensive like way way too
expensive
uh look i love my oculus quest too i use
it all the time i'm such a big fan of
the oculus quest 2.
the reason that i don't care about the
facebook integration stuff which i
definitely agree is off putting is
because i don't use facebook
so i have it linked to a facebook
account that i barely ever use
so none of that really concerns me
because i don't use the platform
i would say i use facebook like once
every three months or something maybe
i'll take a look for a second but it's
not a
platform i even peruse regularly i don't
open the app
nothing so i don't think there's a lot
that you could get from me
via facebook but of course that's a
personal thing in general i would say
maybe don't use facebook if you can
avoid it
but uh i do love the oculus quest too i
really i really do i'm such a fan
i have it with me right here
and i bought my mum one for mother's day
so she now has one as well so maybe we
can play beat saber
from across countries ghost he said was
there a time where you saw a game that
you have a lot of interest or excitement
but it turns out that game is exclusive
on one platform only
and that game won't come out on the
other platforms five or so years when
that happens are you like oh i'm buying
that console to play that game
or decide just to wait for the game to
come out and the other platforms even if
it means waiting for years for that to
happen what's your opinion on that
that's a
long question that is quite a sentence
sir i always make sure that i have all
of the consoles so
platform exclusivity is not an issue for
me of course i know a lot of people
can't afford this but i did it even when
i was a teenager
i was working you know jobs that were
paying me nothing just on weekends and
saving up to just buy my consoles
um to make sure that i had them because
i just really [ __ ] love video games
man you know
so uh for me again i know that there are
a lot of people who can't afford to do
this
no matter their circumstances no matter
if they're teenagers or not
i've just never had to worry about any
kind of exclusivity because i will
always
own everything because video games are
my life and my number one priority
and that is that is pretty well true
that said i do think there is tremendous
value
in being a patient gamer there's a whole
subreddit about it
people who wait uh especially now where
so many games are releasing with
patches or ongoing upgrades like no
man's sky
i really didn't like that game when it
first came out and then the next update
came out and now i love that game
there are basically no downside unless
the servers get disconnected or
something
to being more patient to wait to play a
game
i definitely don't think there's
anything wrong with that taryngias which
sport do you prefer aussie rules or
rugby
and if rugby legal union absolutely
aussie rules
afl i went and saw the lions play a few
weeks ago
and we won and it was wonderful i think
afl is a dope sport
it's so much fun to watch it's really
fast i find rugby pretty funny because i
find like
man piles to be funny but i just really
like the pace of afl
i really enjoy it obviously the sport
that i watch the most is
soccer or football um being you know
english football we call it soccer in
australia too
a lot of brits assume that we call it
football but we also call it soccer here
so i'm used to kind of the speed of that
and afl definitely has some of that
even ludwig asks have you ever played d
if not would you i've never played d d
i would love to in theory but i don't
see myself
having time to play a game like that i
tried once when i was at ign to do a
different role playing game with a bunch
of friends
a bunch of colleagues i just couldn't
fit it into my schedule
there are too many things that i need to
do for me to be able to
play d d i really would love to in
theory that said i am also
a bit awkward about people who get very
into characters
not in a way that there's anything wrong
with them doing that but you know when
like people are playing d d and they're
like performing
um i respect the hell out of it but
something about it
just makes me kind of you know like i
just
get uncomfortable i i couldn't tell you
why
i don't know what it is not all the time
i've just it's just happened to me
before in person where i've been like oh
you're performing
i don't know how to react to that uh
but yeah it's a time issue i just can't
see myself having the time there's so
many things that i need to get done in a
day
you know eternal asks why do you kick so
much makeup on your face
it's gross i get this comment sometimes
and um it's a strange one there was a
tweet once when someone was coming for
me real hard they were like
you know she makes youtube videos with
all that click clickbait thumbnails that
have all the tits in them which
i don't know if there's a single video
on my entire channel
where you can see boobs in the thumbnail
wait i don't know if there's even one
honestly these people don't look i guess
i answered my own question but i was
going to say they
they said that i was click-baiting
people to get more money to buy makeup
so i could cake my face
um i'm not wearing any foundation right
now if i
do that looks exactly the same right if
i'm wiping all my whole face here
and i my face doesn't look any different
right let me just do all this wiping
because i'm not wearing any there's no
foundation on my face there's no blush
there's no concealer
nothing i do pretty much always wear a
little bit of eyeliner
like most of the time i really like
eyeliner um
and i've definitely gotten better at it
recently but i do like makeup as a
practice i know i would never want
anyone to take this as shaming makeup
because
i find it very fun it's uh it is a fun
way to kind of do art
on your own face i don't do it because
as with d d
i feel like i never have enough time i'm
like i don't want to waste
10 minutes doing that when i have so
many other things i could instead be
doing
which is also why my hair's always
really messy sure i could style my hair
but i have other [ __ ] to do and i don't
want to deal with it
anyway yeah no absolutely no makeup
aside from the eyeliner
which is also a day old
guess we're doing the set as far as
working in your new role at sony santa
monica is concerned
what so far would you consider be the
benefits and if there have been any so
far low points of writing in a studio
environment versus producing content on
your own terms
um so i have never been a solo content
producer um
or you know person who has done anything
solo
outside of when i was freelance writing
and that was only as a means to get to a
full-time position i started out as a
freelance writer before
becoming a part-time writer and then
becoming a full-time writer and have
been a full-time writer ever since
for me personally um i really like
working with the team that's the reason
why i've never gone
solo on youtube or twitch not because
you know part of it is that i really
love writing and you don't really get to
do as much of that on these platforms
but
um i like working with teams of people
that i can learn from i like learning i
like
being in an office environment where
people are much smarter than me
and i can absorb their smartness and
become a better human as a result
so working at santa monica studio is
working at a world-class studio where
these people are at the absolute tops of
their fields
are absolute experts on what they do and
for me that is
absolutely wonderful and that's what i
want in any workplace
any career is to be with people who i
find inspirational and educational and
informative and
knowledgeable and to surround myself
with those people so that i can
become better and more knowledgeable
and um you know learn
from the people around me i think that
is pretty much it there is another
question that says biggest gaming regret
but i don't feel like i really have any
my probably the only one i would think
of is the amount of time that i've sunk
into
mmos probably a bit much
overall but i love video games and i'm
grateful for them
in general alrighty everyone that is
it from me today remember you can learn
more about keeps in the description
otherwise i will see you guys next time